embrace the genius of the end if you
have multiple business ideas and
multiple passions try to find a way to
combine them into one ultra awesome
business idea because if you stay
distracted and you're focusing on too
many things at once you will not make it
your business will fail hi I'm Evan
Carmichael and I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and today
mates in a question from one of my
youtube viewers deepak who wrote in to
say i have a question for you Evan I
find focusing difficult how do you
retain focus when there are several
business interests that all seem
interesting so thanks for the question
Deepak and it's a common problem when
entrepreneurs are first starting up they
have tons of different business ideas
they have a lot of different passions
and they're trying to figure out which
one is going to become their baby and if
you really feel like you're pulled in
multiple directions often you find that
some passions are lot stronger than
others but if you really feel you have
two or three try to combine them into
one business idea I'm reminded of my
friend rich who's a photographer and
he's a celebrity photographer and he's
done work with Lady Gaga and lots of
celebrity artists and musicians and he
has a hard time standing out because
there's a lot of photographers and he's
lost some of the interest in his
business and he wanted to focus on
writing the blog that talked about the
things he's discovered in his life he's
a bit off the wall he talks about how it
uses lemon as a deodorant and how he
unschooled his kids not home schools on
schools and I said which you got to
combine those two things that's powerful
because now you're not just a normal
photographer or celebrity photographer
you're the celebrity photographer who
also has this passion and alternate
lifestyle that's going to attract your
ideal clients some people are going to
go to his website and see rich the
photographer and they'll see that he is
interested in you know lemon juice as is
deodorant and some people are going to
see that the stuck-up guys are going to
say that guy's crazy I don't want him to
be my photographer and other people like
Lady Gaga who's crazy well look at that
and say that guy is crazy
I need to have him as my photographer
and so by combining his passions even
though they seem completely unrelated
he's more likely to stand out to his
ideal clients because Lady Gaga will be
more attracted to him and he likes
working with those crazy artist he
doesn't want to work with the boring
CEOs he wants to work with the
off-the-wall crazy people because that's
him so share yourself combine your
passions be the guy who does this and
this and you're the only one who does it
and you're going to attract the people
who have the same interest as you and
they're going to buy more from you
they're going to refer more people on to
you and you can have a lot more fun
working with them if you want to share
more specifics about your passions I'd
love to help you a little bit further
but for those of you who are watching
this video and who are faced with that
dilemma you have to find a way to stand
on your market if you are just a
consultant or if you're just a painter
or if you're just a piano instructor or
just a t-shirt manufacturer whatever it
is you're trying to get into you have to
find a way to be different because
there's tons of competition in whatever
field you get into and the way to send
out is to inject more of yourself into
your business so if you have multiple
passions bring that to your business
you'll bring better customers who will
spend more money and refer more people
and you'll have a lot more fun and bring
more energy to your company embrace the
genius of the end instead of trying to
think about this or this good luck for
those of you watching if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
and love seeing those come in and I'd
love to hear we have to think if you've
a comment about this video or question
for your own business it really makes my
day everytime I see some come in so
leave a comment thank you and I'll see
you on the next episode
you